Hỗ hội đang tương bước thuốc đẩy ứng dụng công nghệ mới, đặc biệt là chỉ tự nhiên tạo,
ei hai, nhanh phục vụ hiệu quả cho hoạt động lập pháp, giám sát tối cao và quyết định các vấn đề quan trọng của đất nước.
Bí ứng dụ, ei hai được kì vọng sẽ hỗ trợ đại biểu của hội trong phân tích,
sử lý thông tin, dự báo tắc động chính sách,
sê dự văn tản quy phạm pháp lực và tăng cửa năng phản ứng kì thời với các vấn đề kinh tệ xác hội đặt ra.
Đông thời, ei hai còn có phần năng cao chất lượng hoạt động sám sát,
miếng bài khoá thông tin và thúc đẩy chuyển đổi số trong công thác quả lĩa nhận nước.
Cú hội xa định đầy là hưởng đi chỉ lực nhằm hiện đại hoá hoạt động nghị trường.
Tăng cửa năng lực thiết chiếc và đáp ứng yêu cầu phát triển nhanh,
bình vững trong thời kì các mạng công nghiệp lần thứ tư.